for so long busy with life aldah yeah
but tell me something we've noticed yeah
and just to let you know yeah that about
40,000 are watching at the moment I how
many people watching majority is about
the the quality of course of course but
but but the point I'm going to make yeah
is that what we've noticed is that not
many Muslims are seem to be coming down
here on Sunday now and it's all about
going on the streets to
Street debate Street da why is it
changing this very good question you
don't expect me to ask rubbish come
sometimes you do I'm going to
lie anyway a good question because Islam
when we preach and give da is act of act
of worship it's an act of worship and in
order for an act of worship to be
accepted According to Islamic teaching
we have we have or we must fulfill two
conditions one of them we have to be
sincerely doing it for Allah alone not
to show off not just to get money not
for the D effort secondly we have to do
it in accordance the teaching of the
Prophet
Muhammad so saying that I've noticed
speak Corner changed it became more like
into violence you know even no long ago
I had to defend myself you know I had to
do what I had to do you understand
because some people maybe they think sh
got rushed we can just walk over him no
I try to stay away from violence I try
to stay away from fighting but I've
noticed speak K is tur into a nasty
place people just coming fighting and
people are debating for the sake of
debating so we've noticed hdah me a a
long time ago the outside industry is
more fruitful so me coming here to give
da is speak K is still good platform to
utilize to send a message and to convey
the message however outside is more
fruitful why cuz outside when the people
stop and come to speak to you genuinely
speaking they want to learn they want to
understand stand speak is becoming more
just to come and just argue for the sake
of argument why do you think controversy
just here to argue for the sake of
arguing is it
because social media has influenced the
way what people are doing down here now
yeah that's one of the reasons I agree
with you social media did or does affect
people however I believe some people
that come to speak Corner every Sunday
some of them is coming from a mental
places I'm not going to lie to you I I
agree with you I've noticed that I've
noticed that some of them they they
coming from a mental places they're
mentally unstable so they have one day
off one day off no clearly I'm not one
of them because the reason I come for
four months I think you are one of them
without any doubt because you keep
coming every Sunday so anyway the point
here is that alhamdulillah we as Muslims
reminded to me first and to my brothers
out there when we give da we're not here
to entertain people me leaving my my
beautiful wife and my beloved wife and
my beloved children to come here then
I'm going to come for a great
purpose which is to worship Allah by
giving da I'm going to come here to
waste my time to entertain non people I
mean to entertain people no you
understand yes sometimes it can be some
entertainment there but the of Da is to
call to Allah and speak to people who
are interested in learning if you notice
the Christians that come here they don't
come here to teach to teach about
Christianity they're just come in here
to disturb and interrupt heck and Heckle
the Muslims and there are some Muslims
too they do that for example there are
some Muslims here they come to just
Hackle me stop me cuz why they have noce
my da is According to Islamic teaching
which came with and they're not happy
with that because why they Wen maybe I
believe they've been paid by the enemies
of Islam to try to send a corrupted
message about Islam but we're not going
to allow allow them to do
that as you know my final Point as you
know I've been to see you doing Street
da standing Shepherd's Bush about 18
months ago when I when am I going to be
invited Street night to come and see you
again well we are out there every Friday
we're not going to stop you if you come
come from what time we we there from
after J so alhamdulillah there from J
all the way to 8:00 p.m. we give da
alhamdulillah and look Subhan Allah
every Friday we do da at least at least
one person except Islam alhamdulillah
sometimes three people why because one
of the the Miracle of Islam it goes in
line with the sound intellect and
natural inclination you know when a
people you explain Islam to people
naturally they'll find themselves
inclining towards Islam you understand
so alhamdulillah I'm not going to stop
you but if you want to come come EXC Mr
sh Lord sh you know we engage ask
question BR you always ask me why why
don't you accept
Islam ask True Believer you know it's
good to do what you doing asking people
everything but you need to think about
yourself first I've answered the
question before I'll answer it again
when I'm here at Speaker's Corner I'm
here I'm here for a purpose for a
purpose and that person's purpose is to
engage with everyone it's not to push my
religion no I'm not tell religion I'm do
you believe in God do you believe in God
I I say when I'm here I believe in no
one no you I'm going say you believe in
God you believe in the Creator you in
big trouble so so so this you will
create
you telling me it's logical rational to
believe this beautiful creation came
without Creator when I'm here at's
corner I don't believe in anything I'm
not asking about here outside I'm
question I'm addressing listen listen
list we can address that when I'm down
political response but stop giving me
political
responses listen listen no no it's not
because I'm asking you you already
answer the first question but when I'm
challing your answer you flipped so
again are you tell telling me this
beautiful well organized Universe came
about without any Creator I have no
knowledge what some here at speak cor
outs speak cor you have knowled wait
so outside speaker corner you have
knowledge so here you have no knowledge
because I engage with so here you have
no knowledge so here you have no
knowledge but outside speakers canot you
do have that knowledge suddenly so
you're lying then when I walk you're
lying when you say you have no knowledge
walk through that door you haven't
listened to my answer when I'm here at
speak when I'm here at speakers call I
have no interest in religion when I'm
outside of Speakers Corner I have an
interest when I when I'm here I so the
question ask you said to you about
theological rational to believe there is
no creator for this beautiful creation
you said you have no knowledge so my
question was to you so outside speaking
you will have that knowledge you said
yes so therefore you you you were lying
when he said no so I can't sh you
anymore man that's you know that's why
one our schol said if you want to sit
with a liar see
journalist that's